[Musique]
et les mois
après avoir été libéré par ses parents
humains ou basse est établi avec un
groupe de bons monstre dans une forêt
reculée et paisible loin du monde des
humains
[Applaudissements]
southampton
[Musique]
m
merci mme s'est passé national
hier
richard
on va où là
un homme au sahara
est ce qu'on peut se sentir mieux sans
cette enveloppe de peau humaine a été
bien plus belle comme ça tu sublime on
nous c'était bien amusant oui le
malfaisant droit monstres et de
l'envoyer ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
celui là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ra 4
par mois
[Musique]
m
là est ce que vous bat s'est échappée
wac oui espérons que tout se passe bien
pour lui
du gras
j'ai un son de l'hymne à gaza il se
contracte israël six mois bientôt qu'on
a été acquise à 50 dans mombris à
montreuil ce match
[Musique]
j'ai encore des visions abah abah abah
abah abah abah abah à eau
mon maître est aveugle est complètement
idiot mais ils entendent parfaitement
bien
il dit qu'il n'a jamais ressenti un peu
aussi étrange de sa vie c'est un peu
comme si tous les désordres
gynécologiques du monde avait été jeté
dans un seul corps abah abah abah
on m veut savoir à quelle date on votre
cycle menstruel c'est si important que
ça vous avez déjà enfanté nul besoin
d'être timide c'est lui la mer 1 le 15
de chaque mois je mange végétarien c'est
tout à part ça je je vais très bien on
attend depuis son accouchement il est
souvent déprimé il a perdu le sommeil
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez guérir il dit
qu'il n'a jamais traité un homme pour
une dépression post natale il n'a
qu'elle traitait comme une femme et moi
c'est ce que je fais avec lui quand vous
sentez vous déprimer quand il pense à
son fils qui ne voient plus
[Musique]
bah il dit que le problème est dans
votre tête
oui prenez ça est fait vous dire le tout
avec trois vols d'eau et puis je mettre
plus d'eau ce sera bien plus facile à
avaler
abah abah vous n'êtes vous pas il ne
faut pas boire sawaba vous devrez la mer
après la ou les bouviers permettre dans
sa soucoupe est planté une piètre
danseur de briller le soleil pour avoir
de l'énergie positive chère
[Musique]
cette histoire dense en est ridicule
l'unique chose qui peut te guérir ses
devoirs ou bas attention c'était moins
une
[Musique]
révèle tac en véritable monstre ouais le
petit moment si je ne vois pas quoi tu
parles
excusez moi car ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
beynat
est-ce que ça va oui regardez moi ça
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour l'eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
s'il est ce que tu es blessé
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes du bureau de la chasse aux
monstres
non
vous êtes aussi des chasseurs on n'est
que du menu fretin
je suis tjrs en in song et voici xao lan
acquis avons-nous launay non à young
king enchanté désolé il faut que je vous
laisse continuer à faire du bon travail
boudeuse
[Musique]
il me fait penser quelque chose du taupe
elle était du bureau de la chasse aux
monstres hui aussi peut-être que si on
va là-bas on y trouvera des indices pour
le localiser nous allons leur rendre
visite
oui
tu penses que booba as peur tu te perds
un trublion comme lui je pense plutôt
que c'est le tonnerre qui a peur de
booba
quand est-ce que tu as fabriqué sa houba
me manque mais je pense que les humains
et les monstres ne peuvent pas encore
coexister quand je regarde cette poupée
et que je lui parle j'ai l'impression
que booba est à mes côtés
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est un vrai monstre à drapeau là
[Musique]
je vois rien
non mais les chats règles ayant allons
chercher autre part ouais allez moi il a
fait pour disparaître comme ça ouais
[Musique]
[Rires]
sumioni quoi oh tu cherches tu es
parents
[Musique]
aidez moi
jeux sont faits c'est un miracle de 15
victoires d'affilée j'avais vu lequel
pareil que pour quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
perdu de sa vie et gagner une fois de
plus est insignifiant mais ça doit vous
aider à rendre cela signifiant alors
la hauteur de votre tapis en un seul
coup vous jouez si vous voulez renoncer
vous pouvez partir avec votre argent
maintenant je ne laisse jamais passer
une occasion
et encore moi il m'est aussi belle que
vous je crois que nous en avons terminé
[Musique]
désolé chère madame
où sont les toilettes si lille est
doivent être au fond n'est ce pas mr
freeze
il semblerait que nous ayons deux
arnaqueurs ici une bonne ne sont pas
arrêter de mentir cette chose est
apparue de votre côté on dirais plutôt
que c'est vous qui trichaient jeu
devrait vous donner une bonne leçon
j'avais salles 3d car ça reste tout de
même à nuancer
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
il est mon corps
[Musique]
à
manet
[Musique]
le sol
bon gars
[Musique]
ses arrières
pas mal
[Musique]
nada
pour ces pots cassés
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce truc
mais moi ma grande époque je me suis
battu contre digue en même temps on
m'avait surnommé le tueur
j'étais vénéré par beaucoup n'ont pas
pour mes compétences exceptionnelles
mais pour mon intégrité
on s'était mis d'accord sur cinq coups
en a joué 15
alors tout ça c'est ma frite à elle pour
le temps supplémentaire plus stricte à
elle pour avoir vomi et puis tu m'a
lâché là bas alors dit à m pour
souffrance mentale
sans compter qu'ils aient raté rendez
vous avec ma copine deux billets tu me
trouves ça aide c'est ça tu as ruiné ma
partie et tu me demande de l'argent tu
n'imagine même pas combien je méprise
les gens avides et c'est pareil pour les
monstres est à chaque fois que je
rencontre
je suis sans pitié ben ben une âme et tu
plaisantes ou moi qui tu restes minus
avec un grand sabre 2 - un couteau
tu as dit été sans pitié avec les gens
avides c'est ça alors utilise le pour te
suicider tu aimerais vraiment salaires
des emails doit bien si tu le fais pas
je demanderai à mach rapide est bouffé
tout cru ma cantine et une très grande
vie tu menaces
très grande elle doit même pas faire ma
tête ça l'effrontée souvient craquage la
peur de rien calme toi je suis un homme
digne avec une réputation à maintenir
je vais te payer boîte ou hewitt ou leur
chute a et u devra aussi payer ta part
subban y serons heureux d'être aussi
dure mieux vaut être dur car c'est bon
ou est-ce que tu as eu le maïs a le
talent de mam aux hommes aux marchés de
l'amérique
quand tu es passera demain essaye dans
la foire puis je te rappelle que tu lui
dois toujours 30 à elle elle a dit que
si tu la rembourse pas tu tues devrait
pousser 23e physique tu parle depuis
elle est deux fois grosses comme toi
jamais de la vie lundi amazon que je
préfère la rembourser t'es qui toi c'est
ton fils caché aucun de ceux rencontrés
[Musique]
silence tu veux tu manges mon maïs et tu
te moques de moi
adieu mon pied et bon voyage
[Musique]
et l'heure de la teigne
betclic
[Musique]
ce monstre n'est qu'elle en fut mais
qu'est ce qui leur prend tiens merci
suivante chassant le bureau de la chasse
aux monstres et riche merci
normalement je devrais être un chasseur
de niveau iii maintenant le salaire doit
être pas mal je devrais être promu aussi
toi tient tant à l'accouchement
[Musique]
e
moi à charrat gauche réparation à droite
et pas de questions je suis occupé au
excusez-nous femmes ont jeté juste un
coup d'oeil
attendez je suis l'armurier comment vous
le savez vous préparez donc les armes et
votre abonnement de l'être
oui elle a été abîmée lors d'une chasse
devinez comment je le sais c'est pas le
moment de jouer aux devinettes tout ce
qu'on veut savoir c'est si vous pouvez
réparer ça se fout et endommagé la
preuve de votre ignorance et de votre
faiblesse
pourquoi ne pas en avoir bien pris soin
c'est totalement irréparable fait pas
attention à lui et je pense que vous
êtes quelqu'un de spécial on dira que
que vous ne vous êtes pas laver les
cheveux depuis deux mois
cela montre que vous ne vous embarrassez
pas des détails
vous voyez les choses en grand tom c'est
moi qui abîme et le fouet sylvia madame
j'ai comme l'impression que nous nous
comprenons et comme ce fou et avoue
quelque part ça m'inspire je crois avoir
trouvé un moyen de réparer le nouvel
savez je sens que nous partageons il
aimerait avoir de nouvelles armes
tout ce que la dame veut elle l'obtient
on ne trouve pas tous les jours
et kaiser merci votre salle est pleine
de trésors qui permettra à plus tard et
merci encore occupez vous bien le fouet
[Musique]
et tu t'es pas content tout à l'heure à
comment tu le sais parce que nous
partageons un lien pourquoi tu clip a
plutôt avec lui tu es jaloux
j'allumais
[Musique]
direct résoudre comment vas quand tu me
dois de l'argent tu m'appelles
directrice quand tu veux en emprunter tu
m'appelles petit sous laquelle des deux
est la vraie moins que ton coeur j'ai
une autre question tâche de bien y
répondre
quand vais je te payer non
quant à lieu notre mariage
si ces dettes ne sont pas remboursés
dans les trois mois qui viennent petit
tout épousera ça bien mais mes petites
joues tu as signé ce contrat de mariage
et tu là même celle et d'un baiser
tu m'as fait boire et tu m'as fait
signer je croyais que c'était une
reconnaissance de dette
l'argent je m'en fiche j'ai vérifié le
calendrier est aujourd'hui est un jour
parfait pour un mariage aujourd'hui que
tu plaisantes
sans nos parents ni un marieur on peut
pas faire ça tu n'as pas l'intention de
m'épouser n'est ce pas tu n'es qu'une
ordure
[Musique]
choisi la fille que tu préfères
je peux choisir celle que je veux tu
peux me choisir moi aussi
[Musique]
un petit coup de brosse rien de
sophistiqué
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parle quand vas-tu règle était tête je
veux vous remboursez vraiment sauf que
je n'ai pas l'argent est bien choisi
notre rugby
[Musique]
je vais vendre
[Rires]
on serait tous trois jours ci des mon
corps dans les volumes ceux qui disaient
avoir trouvé nos petits monstres senti
si tu vas ne participe aux modes
[Musique]
suivants suivant
pas tant patronne tout pourrait mourir
si nous continuons ça suffit s'il meurt
qui va m'épouser qui va m'épouser
on vous n'êtes que des idiotes et vous
c'est lui que je veux vous avez vu ce
que vous m'amenez vous vous fichez de
moi ou quoi tu cherches ce petit gars
celui qui dit tout le temps vobruba
juste eh oui là on n'est pas inclus et
mois entraîne souvent ensemble ramène le
moi je serai prête alors à faire des
efforts roda faveur
[Musique]
et moi
pas tous
risque du pays maladroit ses pairs ne
touchez pas ça vous donne
comment osez-vous ces tablettes sont
sacrés c'est celle de mon père oui
juncker
tu es le fils de daikin chambre vous
connaissez mon père c'est mon supérieur
j'ai avec moi son épée c'est la preuve
que je suis son fils
je te crois tu as les yeux de ton père
mon père est vraiment mort frères tsonga
disparu il ya dix ans dans la ville des
eaux claires personne ne sait s'il est
vivant ou mort maintien nil et moi avons
cherché partout mais malgré nos efforts
il reste introuvable
ce sont les mémoires de chasse aux
monstres deux frères song
peut-être y trouvera tu des indices qui
nous aurait échappé frères yonnais que
je trouve mon père ou pas merci pour
votre aide nous sommes tous des
chasseurs ça fait de nous des frères
le sort de ton père montre que le
conflit entre les humains et les
monstres n'a pas été réglée mais il
n'est facile pour aucun d'entre nous de
résoudre ce problème
la légende dit qu'un petit monstre e
modifier cette situation
en effet c'est le fils de l'ancien roi
monstre ses cheveux sont comme de
l'herbe et il fait une sorte de bruit
quand il est heureux ou bas mais il a
lui aussi disparu à nous devons
absolument le retrouver
j'aimerais vous montrer quelque chose
vous me suivez
[Musique]
voici la dune de sable de lobbying mais
chasseurs l'utilisent pour traquer les
monstres quand un monstre le désir
ardent de voir un membre de sa famille
la dune a le pouvoir de ressentir ce
désir est aussi de montrer où se trouve
ce membre
et ça marche pour les humains à vrai
dire on n'a jamais essayé
si tu veux tenter le coup pour ton père
ou pour quelqu'un d'autre ne te gêne pas
rayonné on a perdu pique nique
mais on vient d'attraper sa mère elle
traînait dans le coin
les monstres à pointe adultes sont
dangereux pour les humains
après ça il faudra éliminer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon fils
ah ah
[Musique]
et la forêt de tianzhu chasseurs allons
six frères young
peut-on venir avec vous
[Musique]
pique nique ta mère est morte
d'inquiétude vous avoir rencontré maman
oui tout à l'heure pourquoi que turinois
mois souviens tu as sauvé un humain
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes là pour tuer ou pour le
capturer
y'a pas différents arrêtés
[Musique]
tu as vraiment ma vie je il s'enfuit
attendait pic-pic m'a dit qu'il avait
sauvé un humain monstres sont des
montants il faut l'abattre
il détruit les pièges à monstres tout
comme les humains il y a des bons et des
mauvais monstre allons d'abord cherché
des réponses
nous ne te feront kamal un conte moi qui
a dû sauver chasse a beaucoup piège
plessé des humains enfants j'ai sauvé
maison du jeu détruit veulent tuer moi
frères young piqué blessés si on le
ramène vous promettez de ne pas lui
faire de mal
le bureau rendre un jugement équitable
est ce que tu sais que tu manques à ta
mère tu me manque beaucoup
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu sais
que depuis que tu es parti j'ai peur de
ne plus jamais te revoir
[Musique]
dans ce monde
rien n'est plus douloureux que d'être
séparé de sa famille
c'est pourquoi
tu ne peux pas l'abandonner
ravis avec nous je t'en prie retourne
auprès de ta maman tu veux bien
[Musique]
j'ai toujours dit que tu devrais être
plus indulgent ce petit radier si
mignons ils auraient pu rester avec nous
et tu m'as forcée elle vire et tu es
vraiment un sens coeur ou au tout non ça
va hein
si tu voulais qu'il reste pourquoi tu ne
m'as pas arrêté tu dois apprendre à
avoir du cran ne vont pas ou beaucoup
s'il te plaît ce pauvre petit chauve sa
famille je crois et qu'est ce qu'on y
gagne
écoute moi bien l'argent résout les
problèmes pas les sentiments j'ai des
dettes réglées
tu veux que vous me tu ne tueras pas un
les folles de tous sans parler que si tu
te marier avec elle la fille de ma ma
langue sera en course c'est toi que je
devrais vendre
[Musique]
bendel encore en train de jouer à
cache-cache on attend voir que je
t'attrape enfin de voilà donc mon pire a
dit que ça fait un moment tu m'as manqué
au nom donc être pas je suis là pour te
ramener chez tes parents
est-ce que tu as faim
comment peux-tu cracher sur la personne
qui le nourrit tu vas voir ce que tu
vois que tu va le frapper les monstres
ne crache pas sur ce qu'ils aiment ou à
témoin et ils vous bat booba tu as perdu
la tête d'ali ti fujia malgré le fait
qu'ils soient emprisonnés
du moment qu'ils sont ensemble ils sont
heureux qu'est ce que tu fais je
réfléchis
comment les libérer regarderai je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il s'en préoccupe
et si on les laisse partir et qu'ils se
font prendre par d'autres gens tu crois
vraiment que c'est plus sûr ici
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai eu une idée frère
pourquoi est-ce que tu les a libérés tu
as vu des mois et pas qu'un peu
[Musique]
c'est une composition florale
c'est parfait comme ça mais c'est la
gauche veut faire léviter des objets
réclame de la concentration
quoi tu pas ça je ne pense à rien du
tout je vais donner une leçon à tous
pour toi tu sais ce qui se passe quand
tu craches sur les gens aient battu créé
entre eux et toi une sorte de connexion
tu sais ce que ça veut dire en gros si
tu as une forte émotion tous les gens
sur qui tu a craché verrons ce que tu
vois ce moment là
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé l'optimum par leurs affaires
pensant tu es si belle
je sais je sais et si tu m'embrasses es
[Musique]
tu ne mérites pas à lui j'aime la façon
dont tu me regardes d'aujourd'hui
cependant ça manque de compliments
quelques mots suffiront
tu pourrais juste dire non au lieu de me
mettre un coup de poing tu traînes la
patronne de vache comment as-tu osé
faire ça
excuse moi mon amour je ne voulais pas
faire ça j'ai vu quelque chose de très
répugnant devant moi bardon te voilà
méchant maintenant donne moi un monstre
et tout de suite j'ai pas dit la vache
dans ce sens là j'ai dit la bâche dans
le sang soit à la vache elle est
magnifique je te jure qu elle est divine
à mes yeux tu penses vraiment ce que tu
dis oui absolument
[Musique]
ton visage aujourd'hui ressemble des
grosses fesses je peux savoir ce qui se
passe à trois noms laissez-moi du coupé
la langue il est clairement aveugle je
devrais lui arracher les yeux lalande
d'abord les yeux d'abord tu as été trop
loin je pense sincèrement que tu es
magnifique aujourd'hui mais je te jure
sur ma vie que j'ai bien vu des fesses
en face de moi tout à l'heure est ce que
j'ai l'air d'une idiote à ce point là je
préfère faire confiance à un diable kata
bush si je ne peux pas t'avoir
personne ne t'aura atout non attends tu
peux avoir le monstre gratuitement
jamais tu as le malheur de me mentir
encore je te préviens je te couperai ce
que tu a de plus cher au monde
[Musique]
un chien c'est toi tu t'amuses et à
faire ça je me souviens de ta vieille
blessure à l'épaule il est temps de la
soigner laisse moi te faire un massage
pourquoi es tu si entreprenant
aujourd'hui chez toi ne bouge pas je
reviens tout de suite mais qu'est ce
qu'il a
[Musique]
et les mois
espace à rigaud pourquoi t'as fait ça je
veux pas que tu vends de booba les
flashs que j'eus avanade hui et comment
c'est possible un truc pareil depuis
qu'il est à cracher dessus tu peux voir
ce qu'il voit quand il a un choc
émotionnel ou physique et qu'il crie
[Musique]
j'ai vu les bras de rumba aurait pu le
dire [ __ ] t'as jamais mordu
le petit sous un jour donne moi un jour
de plus je t'emmènerai le petit monstre
demain j'en ai assez de me faire avoir
assez de croire tu mens comme tu
respires pourquoi te mentir je fais moi
confiance
[Musique]
est ce que tu peux me prêter sans taille
je ne signerai un nouveau serment
[Musique]
petit ou m eur à petit pour l'éternité
merci
il vous roule encore patronne il vous
manque vous savez vaud j'ai regardé ses
yeux
j'ai senti son coeur battre et puis il
ya ceux ci son sermon pas trop regarder
on en est à combien de fois
patronne
[Musique]
voyez vous ça très bien
akron allons soyez pas si triste
vous ne savez rien de l'amour
trouvez-moi du beau papier
nous commençons un nouveau compte
[Musique]
mon petit bout de bas je sens que toi et
moi on va faire un malheur aux majors
ce n'est juste qu'une paire de bras ce
ne sont peut-être pas ceux de houba
détends toi mon père n'était pas très
populaire au bureau de la chasse aux
monstres
il en a libéré beaucoup vun à capturer
que les mauvais oh il est dit ici que
l'épée de mon père peut changer de
taille quand elle quand elle grandit
elle est efficace sur les monstres
géants le mot magique est sous l'eau
sous l'eau peut-être koulouba et c'est
me parlait à travers mes rêves
[Musique]
ivoire
hier soir
dragons père
[Musique]
j'ai encore gagné mais comment ça se
fait que tu aies toutes les tuiles qu'on
veut c'est impossible c'est ma place
c'est pas vrai qu'est ce que tu fais la
cuy tu devrais pas être en train d'aider
ta mère à vendre du maïs c'est pas tes
affaires joue oui watts
[Musique]
je revois des chaudes 9 one et qu'est ce
que tu as vu cette fois du maïs
[Musique]
quoi sert la fois cette moustache et mon
porte bonheur
j'ai toujours de la chance quand je la
mets vous me rappeler quelqu'un sauf que
son nez n'est pas aussi groupe le vôtre
[Musique]
c'est un mets de la fortune il attire la
richesse veut votre opecst personnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon bah je viens de voir booba
[Musique]
l'hôtel amour bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
photo
sans quoi ce qui lui paraît vous
nouvelle vie dit oui ton costume de tire
toi et vous étiez passé où vous arrêtez
de rêvasser
et ce soir c'est pas qu'il commence
encore atterri chez il n'oublie pas de
distribuer les actes rendre à tous
[Musique]
le trouvait pas chez ya que des artistes
ici vous devriez essayer ailleurs désolé
je ne peux pas vous raccompagner passé
une bonne nuit et ne manquez pas de
revenir pour regarder le spectacle
qu'est ce que tu fais chant choral à toi
tout à temps allez c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et là me vassy tous moi c'est ma
première mois non c'est vrai quelle
coïncidence moi aussi nous restions
casser cette pierre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
excusez moi il faut pas m'en vouloir
c'est toi qui m'a dit d'y aller plus
fort lève-toi et swing 60 ans
[Applaudissements]
bon sang qu'est ce que tu fous là tu as
oublié que tu étais dans le prochain
numéro
allez rentrer là dedans vim
encore toi tu es un clown août est un
magicien les affaires sont dures
je fais tout ce que le battre on me dit
de faire quant à ta ta ta ta ta me dis
pas que c'est encore dernière fois non
lamy je fais ce numéro depuis plus de 20
ans très inquiète
désolé j'y suis allé un peu fort là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon on a fini à tout à fait
découper sa titre
[Applaudissements]
lui pourtant
[Musique]
il n'est pas vraiment mort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
tu vois il va très bien je vais bien ne
pleure pas tiqué
reprenons les recherches des gars je
suis sûr que ce petit monstre est
toujours dans le coin il a fait déjà
capturé il est là qu est ce que je vous
avais dit
[Applaudissements]
debra s'était caché
[Musique]
on n'a aucune indication comme on veux
tu qu'on le trouve
dis moi pourquoi on cherche encore ton
père alors lui non plus on ne sait pas
où il se trouve
calmons nous d'abord chérie tu veux bien
est ce que tu veux retrouver vos barres
ou pas bien sûr que oui à temps ne me
dis pas que tu crois que je suis folle
tianjin
je suis ta femme et tu me crois pas
vente le voir lui tu tu as vu du maïs et
des fesses c'est plutôt louche d'accord
si tu me fais confiance vient avec moi
si jamais c'est le contraire ne
t'approche pas de nous après que je leur
ai retrouvé je sais qu'il te manque et
j'aimerais qu'il soit là aussi mais ou
pas est un monstre sa place et dans le
monde des monstres le monde des humains
est dangereux pour lui
il me manque aussi mais sa sécurité
prime c'est n'importe quoi
tu crois vraiment que le monde des
monstres et moins dangereux pour lui et
puis il a peut-être envie d'être avec sa
famille comme tout le monde pourquoi
est-ce que tu l'entends pêche c'est moi
qui lui ai donné naissance je fais ce
que je veux
cette fois tu allé beaucoup trop loin
sur mille je suis aussi là même de booba
teillage
[Musique]
vous pensez qu'on a marché un peu trop
vite
il boite après tout peut-être qu'il n'a
pas pu nous rattraper mais pourquoi est
ce qu il ne m'a pas appelé du genre non
là je suis désolé c'est vrai quoi
il m'arrive de remporter quelques fois
mais j'ai quand même bon caractère
vous êtes d'accord je suis soupe au lait
malgré le fait qu'il soit emprisonné du
moment qu'ils sont ensemble ils sont
heureux
[Musique]
il fait que baver ou cracher ce petit il
a un problème de mâchoires de l'humour
et lescun tranquille tu va le réveiller
tu devrais être plus gentil avec lui de
toute ta vie
personne d'autre ne jamais verser une
larme pour toi
[Musique]
honey pot pour rester ici toute la nuit
oh
[Musique]
et moi
booba
[Musique]
izia golan
on va essayer ensemble
[Musique]
le sud l'a perdu
j'en suis sûr
des eaux claires il est à côté d'ici
[Musique]
j'y vais tout seul d'accord c'est mieux
je crois d'accord comme tu voudras mais
dépêche toi je viens de fabriquer ce
traîneau il est parfait pour deux
personnes asseyez-vous extra je suis
venu pour jeu c'est waouh joli travail
et toutes ses armes assez gentil merci
votre combat attendait
[Musique]
j'ai quelque chose de spécial pour vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
encore merci pour les armes
merci beaucoup il n'y a pas que les
armes vous pouvez aussi avoir ce riz
soufflé cuilhe à haute température très
nutritif et de religieux pour la route
génial merci encore aux douaniers m'y
attendais j'ai encore autre chose pour
vous ces multifonctions
vous pouvez l'utiliser comme lanceur de
sorts pour attaquer des monstres ou pour
cuire du riz
c'est aussi une salière fait un
inventaire fantastique
nous vous remercions infiniment désolés
mais là faut vraiment consommé
madame en faites vous là je comprends
inutile d'en dire plus momo moi aussi je
comprends moi j'ai rien compris
[Musique]
allons voir de ce côté là
on fait quoi maintenant
à ton avis on va au casino tu aurais pu
en ouvrira avec l'argent que tu as perdu
tu oublies ce que je viens de dire on
m
dépêche
ou est-ce qu'il peut être il est
certainement déchets
elle veut faire pipi
[Musique]
mon dieu
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
venez défier les goomba fait pas du tout
les sépare tu te quittera plus jamais
pardonne moi ou bas ne pleure pas on ne
sera plus jamais c'est pas je te promets
qu'on sera toujours ensemble désormais
[Musique]
rendez-nous vous pas tout de suite
monsieur tigre ou bas est notre fils
votre fils qu'est ce que vous sentez là
c'est un monstre
et moi je suis le fils du cousin du mari
de la demi-soeur de dieu le père dubai
tes dettes
[Applaudissements]
désolé mec qui trouve cas si vous le
voulez il faut payer combien mille
tonnes c'est quoi nourrir même temps
qu'à côté croyez pas que je ne suis pas
en courant pour ce monstre il y en a qui
paieront plus cher
nous n'avons pas une telle somme
d'argent mais le bureau de la chasse aux
monstres oui le pur on c'est un piège
c'est ça de quels pièges vous voulez
parlez vous voulez de l'argent et nous
on veut récupérer ou bas on y va
d'accord je vous fais confiance vous
autres si je vous dois de l'argent
suivez nous
[Musique]
milton
c'est ça non négociable et combien tu
veux pour le grand jeu le vent au poids
milles par kilo
[Musique]
ben je veux pas venir avec toi
tu as ton argent tu n'as plus besoin de
moi
comme tu veux
je m'en sortirai j'ai besoin de personne
alors adieu
[Musique]
merci beaucoup frères youn turnier
mémoire nous vous sommes redevables
[Musique]
trayons cette créature n'appartient pas
au monde des humains mais à celui des
monstres je les emmène tout de suite
[Musique]
monde des monstres je peux vous y
emmener vous avez un moyen de locomotion
je sais où harvey sud et moi un sacré
numéro tout mon argent 6 x 3 pièces ouah
on érige les gars est-ce que ça pour toi
et un pour toi aussi
alors j'ai des bonbons
[Musique]
votre chance le pactole
bonjour bonne chance
est ce vraiment comme ça qu'un monstre
devrait se comporter qu'est ce que tu
fais maintenant et tu puisses après
avoir pété
c'est quoi cette mauvaise habitude sécu
le travail qu'a demandé ce costume et à
quel point son tissu est rare tu as
besoin d'une instruction militaire
[Musique]
quoi tu manges pas c'est si mauvais que
ça elle va revenir
[Musique]
et moi
est ce que tu sais à quel point j'aime
ce costume
on ne t'a jamais dit de ne pas pissé sur
les vêtements des gens l'autre du monde
des monstres juste devant
[Musique]
oh
tous
[Musique]
non
ou est ce qui se passait
[Musique]
les monstres à gros ventre qui nous ont
attaqués à la clinique sous les
chasseurs qui était derrière youn ils
nous ont tendu un piège depuis des ces
moments d'utiliser dans nos vertes 1 oui
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais bon
[Musique]
on
cette armure y est un génie
[Musique]
pas du tout je les trouve tellement il
fons après lui bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les facteurs groupe à
j
[Musique]
je
accroche-toi coeur pour moi
on
[Musique]
alors
zut
[Musique]
à
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au départ mais fais attention
[Musique]
non
sous bâti chao gyan le fait vous bah tu
vas le payer très cher
quand je te disais cma comme une vue ce
genre balèze et elles valent aussi
comment vous vous embrasser non c'est
juste une simple curiosité j'ai trouvé
ça en chemin elle brille tellement que
j'ai cru que c'était de l'or merci
monsieur tigre pourquoi tu venu ici
[Musique]
j'ai réalisé que je peux pas vivre sans
toi brume ou un ppt essilor du gop
vraiment tôt
amour avec toi des pechos fortune ce
monstre
[Musique]
vous savez
bakou
[Musique]
à
nous petits cachotiers pourquoi tu m'as
jamais parlé de ton arme secrète
quand je me mens tu ne restons pas là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
c'est vraiment nécessaire d'être aussi
grand ne me dis pas que tu te lâche toi
et je vais j'achète et je trouvais
quatre cas d'accord des formes et booba
revient ici
[Musique]
booba va attaquer
ça marche pas j'espère qu'il a quelque
chose de bien
pourquoi vous faites ça parce que c'est
un ordre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
je viens de me voir il t'a cracher
dessus aussi
mais alors ça veut dire que n'importe
qui sur chivu bas à cracher vous verra
si tu le vois quand il crie une fête
c'est bien beau tout ça et après est ce
que tu as une idée il faut que je
réfléchisse je sais mais pour ça
fonctionne va falloir travailler
ensemble tu as bien compris tu es sûr
[Musique]
maintenant belga
l'été peut se transformer le mot magique
celle soul ou le bas rhin
[Musique]
à
appathurai
fermez les yeux jean-pierre du tout
technique d'accord
[Musique]
au bar
quoi
dom le mois sacré
[Musique]
j'espère qu'un jour les monstres
pourront vivre avec les humains sans
avoir à se cacher sous de la peau
humaine
ce serait merveilleux je pourrai alors
me promener tout nu c'est déjà ce que tu
fais tu devrais avoir honte de nous
avoir laissé tomber comme ça je suis
quelqu'un de très loyal
quand j'ai dit que j'allais chercher du
renfort je manquais pas voici la cuisine
de ma copine est encore plus belle
excuse joffé pressentiment et demande à
la cousine de ta copine de ramener ou
bas et sa famille je te perds est le
double pas de problème je le ferais
gratuitement
izia ou l'année mois nous te remercions
la peine de me remercier
j'insiste merci c'est bon c'est vrai
j'ai dit ça va booba dit que tu devrais
arrêter d'aller jouer au qu'elle soit en
tapant unis celui-là je vous jure
[Musique]
vous bat booba tu vas me manquer prends
soin de toi
gros tibia il soit sage
[Musique]
arrête de pleurer benben allons-y
c'est bien la première fois depuis que
je te connais que je te vois pleurer
tout la ferme
je me demande pourquoi vous ban n'a pas
encore cracher dessus parce qu'il ne
t'aime pas fini
et tu disais qu'il m'aimait pas rien je
comprends maintenant pourquoi pic pic et
sa mère peuvent être heureux
même en prison peu importe que nous
soyons dans l'une des monstres ou des
humains ce qui compte le plus c'est de
rester unis en famille
petit zoo me manque un peu
n'allez pas si méchant que ça tu penses
à la cousine de tout à l'heure un homme
ridicule
j'ai bien vu la façon dont tu la
regardes est inutile de mortier vous
voyez donc ça c'est vrai qu'elle est
jolie silhouette
je savais pas que c'était un truc est ce
que tu pourrais me prêter de l'argent
j'aimerais l'invitent à dîner quoi elle
doit avoir un énorme appétit
ça va te coûter cher benben évite de
m'appeler benben devrait elle se fait
gros ballots d'ailleurs en parlant de ça
tu sais que j'ai failli appeler bang
bang
1 pourquoi tu lapin feu n'a pas demandé
[Musique]
m